Oh what is going on - now recently there
has been some positive news Justin
Bieber is going to jail I'm playing
halfway sort of kind of out but there
have been a lot of questions about how I
feel about this card news topic so
personally do I feel bad for the little
girl Hale [ __ ] no
now let me just put this out there for
some reason every time something happens
to Justin Bieber why don't we act like
it's the biggest news on earth I swear
happy you out there act like he went to
jail for saving a baby gorilla you know
from a forest fire some [ __ ] but it's
[ __ ] just eaten a beater ain't nobody
give a [ __ ] mmm Justine I don't know
what's going on what you like but here's
a couple things that you should be
mindful of you can't go to jail doc what
do you think it do you have any idea
what it's like in there hmm
in case you haven't seen your reflection
in years you want one vagina head okay
from turning into a flat-chested lesbian
I said it you know what you look like
you like with the bougie [ __ ] that bein
himself in coconut oil and baking powder
every night look I don't know how else
to say it to you but they will filet
mignon your booty hole in there Oh God
this ain't the movies you little [ __ ]
you're not gonna walk out there with
some street cred [ __ ] if anything you
walk out there with a limp from having a
dick up your ass listen to me some of
these uneducated [ __ ] haven't
seen a woman in years and you are the
closest thing they have to get their GED
that's right a GED a good-enough Dyke I
could only imagine the carnage that
you're going to go through makes me
giggle how much you want to bet they
gonna sexually assault us and make you
sing you hit singles shake it boy play
baby
baby baby nah pitching the other song
so do I [ __ ] a rule listen my thing
with you is that you are making a lot of
money you're chillin you're making don't
ask music so on the [ __ ] are you acting
out you're not a sad little baby why
would you even want to be personally I
don't even think does want to be thugs
they're just a product of their
environment and you have not experienced
that you got it made son you don't have
to prove [ __ ] to anybody you know who
the [ __ ] you are you are justice beaver
you're any idea how much money and power
you have you little [ __ ] huh I bet you
right now if you are in jail you can get
a cambodia [ __ ] to come to your cell
and fluff your ballsack like a little
tea bag and you know what here's another
thing with all that cash why aren't you
doing baller [ __ ] and just to break this
down do you know what I mean by that hmm
you're buying gold chains airplanes and
cocaine that's not all the baby anybody
with money can buy that regular [ __ ] if
I pay 40 million dollars in a fiscal
year let me tell you what I do I would
personally hire a Skye intense to create
the world's first unicorn with Ben I
said that [ __ ] free shoot the
[ __ ] even unicorn steak then
drape this hat over my ballsack Fowler
look this is my point everybody out
there that's supporting this little
douches bad habits it stop but I don't
give a [ __ ] about this psychological
battle talking about all of this fans
that expect certain things out of him
have created a monster
[ __ ] that [ __ ] your choice is your life
your decisions you live with it and this
is a life lesson for a lot of us out
there because if you don't know already
you are who you surround yourself with
if he makes a choice to hang out with a
lot of people that does drugs
notice I don't know cook up last crack
then go ahead do you little girl is not
my life but I don't feel bad for
somebody who lives in a first world
country with choices and has a [ __ ] ton
of money now Justin if you somehow ever
get to watch this in all seriousness let
me ask you this can I borrow some money
just a couple thousand hey [ __ ] you I'm
a sellout broke your [ __ ]
God do what about Lou Oh Mike he's gonna
miss a couple thousand dollars don't
don't
Oh what is going on YouTube it is toss
the rest
Casa Rex hope you guys liked that video
and I do listen to requests which is why
I did this video so if you guys have
articles or whatever top is you want me
to talk about send it my way and of
course I'm gonna read it
listen and then maybe your topic might
be on next week so once again if you
guys don't know already gear brought to
you by go-for-broke apparel dot-com we
got a couple new designs coming out on
February 5th and trust me it's gonna be
dope as hell sometimes I like to do this
in my chair yeah I apologize you guys
for bringing this video out a little
late I know I'm supposed to be out on
Sundays but I got backed up because I'm
doing and working on an acoustic EP
that's right your boy used to sing I had
some pilots right here
and not know there's her automata do
that's a vocal fight but thank you guys
for tuning in and remember funny fat fit
is this Wednesday yes it's coming up and
we got a lot more ways to go cuz I've
got big duffle chair so I'll see y'all
in a couple days and of course next
Sunday / Monday you will see another
video peace out
done triangle doing what I do go for
broke what Oh get it this end the
[ __ ] video here we go how would you
want to bet they're gonna sexually
assault you and make you sing this in
here how much you want to bet they're
gonna sexually assault you and make you
senior sit you know what you look like
you look like you bagged yourself in
coconut oil and be gay was it